If you don't find shit to do,
you want to lose your mind,
you would get addicted to that.
I just want to learn shit.
You would like it because there's so
much to learn. That's the thing about it.
It's a, it's a long, long
never ending, never ending,
never ending journey of shit.
There's also,
there's so many different variations
of each different individual move and
entries into new moves and defense
and then the structure of it is, it's,
it gets so crazy. It's, so, it's
super complicated. My son does, uh,
my son is heavy into boxing and
karate. I got him into those. So he,
he does them both.
So the reason why I want to do,
I just like to keep up with him so
we can, you know, do things together.
I have trained as come to the house and
we'll work out together. He loves it.
So I just don't want
to get left behind too.
My kids do the kick your
ass when you get 17, 18,
which you say, Dad, hold on.
Oh boy. I don't want that
boy. You better back up. Yeah.
When he started getting
that much confidence.
I just want to be able
to keep up and maintain.
So that's why I like to do it with them.
What's good for a kid to have that
in your head where he's got to defend
yourself. Confidence. You
need that for confidence.
It'll help you avoid things
too. Well, I tell my kids,
you know your last name puts a target
on your back that you didn't ask for and
we don't go and create problems,
but you should always be prepared
for problems if they were to occur.
And if they do, I just want you
guys to know how to defend yourself.
So the things that I have my kids doing,
it's just have the
knowledge and understanding.
The worst thing is just not knowing.
You know,
they're growing up completely different
than I grew up where I grew up.
You had no choice but to know if you
ain't not a fight that shit ass cause you
go gonna get tested. There's no way
around it. You're going to get tried,
you're going to get robbed,
you're going to get your book bag taken.
Somebody will try to take
sneaks like it's the reality.
It's not a false reality that's real.
So if you're not prepared for it,
if you don't have any type of heart,
you won't. Last. From where I grew up,
heart was everything.
And heart was sometimes saying,
I don't care if I get my ass whooped, I'm
not going to be a bitch. I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna allow y'all to
think that this can happen.
So I'm going to lose today, but tomorrow
I'm a come back and I'm gonna find you.
I'm going to talk.
Whatever that moment was,
it was about establishing any level of
respect that you could and I respect
eventually turned into
friendship from all.
So my kids don't know what that world
is like. They're never going to have it.
So as a parent,
I just have to make sure that you have
all the tools that I can possibly equip
you with because my parents didn't have
the ability to provide me with that.
They weren't in the financial space
to to take me here and had this
extracurricular activity or this
extracurricular activity or learn this,
learn that.
Didn't exist.
That is the big conundrum of successful
bird connection when successful people
have kids. The what made them
successful as dry. I grew up poor too.
We were on welfare and food,
the whole deal when I was
a little kid and that
always stuck in my head.
This thought like we might
not have enough food.
Like I remember thinking that when I was
little like what if we don't have any
food? What if we run out of food?
My kids will never feel that.
They don't understand what that is.
And everybody that I've ever met
that's interesting came from some crazy
struggle. Yeah. When they were young.
Yeah. And that's the thing of you're,
you and I and most people
that are doing well in life,
you're raising your kids in a completely
different way than literally what
brought you to the dance
and the first list.
The hunger of not being one
of those people that's left
behind is what makes you
successful in the first.
Yeah.
And it's scary. It's scary because,
you know, my wife, my wife told me,
she was like, you know, I love
that you're not hard on your kids,
but you always make sure there's
a lesson within your conversation.
Like I don't yell.
I yell at my kids.
Nothing's going to register when I'm
yelling. So I try my best to talk to you.
Even when I'm at my angers,
I'm a talk to you.
So you can process this because you
need to understand what's the problem.
You need to understand what's wrong
and what I had to really realizes they
didn't ask to be born into this.
Yeah. You know what I mean?
Like it's not their fault,
right.
That they're coming up completely
different than how we were raised. Right.
And we can't have anger or frustration
that's dedicated than thrown towards them
because they got it so much
better than what we had.
How do we make sure we pass down a proper
lessons so that they appreciate and
understand and not take for
granted, right. They have, for me,
it's tough because could
kiss because students,
they apply themselves to school.
They listen. They don't do dumb shit.
Yeah. They want to play video games
and stay up like any other kid. Yeah.
There's no signs of a bad or or or crazy.
Yeah.
And the fear and panic is that you
gotta noted bad and crazy exists,
right? This fairy tale or
they were in isn't real.
And at some point when I'm not around,
when your mother's not around,
when you have friends or other family
on around, you may get tested. What?
The other side that's out here
that you never seen, right.
So I got to prepare you for the
shit that you don't know exists.
I got to take you to Philadelphia.
So you can see,
I tried to show my kids where I grew
up thinking it's going to be like a,
Oh my goodness backfired. There's
so cool. Can we live here? Shut up.
[inaudible] he hit a car right
now around you talk about this.
When we get back, there's, this does not
go as opposed to, oh my God, so cool.
Dad is so different.
Oh my goodness.
Walked him around the neighborhood
and it's like, it's, it's,
it's not a reality.
You didn't have grass canister.
Oh, that's great. Did you
play wow when you hear, yeah.
When you hear these things,
it's so different. Men.
These were your steps. The steps
are broken. How did you even play?
Oh my God, Dad. So wait,
where? Where was yours?
We lived on the top floor.
Knocked the whole thing. No, it's,
this is three separate units.
So to top floor was me and grand moms.
The middle,
there was somebody else
that was a neighbor and
downstairs with somebody else,
three different people lived
in this one thing together.
Y'All are strangers like, Hey, shut up,
ready to get this in my own ads.
It's everybody in the car get a car.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to say at this part.
Get right in the car.
But when you see that that's the
reality that you get hit with of,
I gotta make sure that I'm talking,
I've got to make sure that I'm
constantly teaching. Yeah. If I'm not,
then I'm not doing my part.
I'm failing. You know,
took them to the neighborhood and showed
them how stores are in the neighborhood.
It's where we got candy from.
Here's,
here's what we would get a little
sandwiches from y'all walk.
We don't have no stores like this.
We can't walk the stuff.
It's a completely different world.
See people standing on the street
corners, what they doing? A B,
they selling drugs. That's,
that's tough right there.
Those are people that your dad still
knows. They've been there forever.
That's what you don't want to do,
but they're forced with these decisions
just because of what they have to do.
You just need to see this dad to take you
here to see this drove them all around,
all around North Philadelphia,
all around South Philadelphia
made sure they could see it.
You got to physically see,
we go out the country.
We go to these resorts and islands.
Before we go there,
we're going to drive around so you can
see what exists before you get to this.
This is why we have to be good people.
This is why we treat everybody
with respect. This is why
your dad likes to give.
Everybody doesn't have,
I'm constantly beating my kids with
that information because then you assume
that everybody does.
You come off like such an ass hole when
you're around people that don't. Yeah.
Why?
How did you,
you don't also have Anders that they
had grown up the way they are now.
It's such a rare thing and they don't
understand that there's no way there's a
small percentage. Yeah,
a very small percentage.
And that's something that I'd
never want to let go of either.
So I was in the back of my head is all
you're talking about how, you know,
are we going to have enough
food when you were coming up?
Chris rock joke is so great that he used
to tell about how he keeps a bag packed
at the front door cause he don't
believe that this shit is his.
He said,
I truly believe that at any point
somebody's gonna go. Got You.
You thought you lived here,
did this joy. And I was like,
it's so real because
even though you have it,
you can't lose the sight of
reality of what once was. Yeah.
Yeah.
Do you,
are you comfortable where you are now
or do you still have those thoughts like
this is this real because you're,
you're at the stratosphere
of fame and success. That's,
it's rare amongst the rare, you know,
it's uh, like David Goggins said,
you are uncommon amongst uncommon men.
I will be a hundred percent
honest and say I'm comfortable
with the understanding of hard
work brings great rewards.
This is a reminder of the hard work and
dedication that I put into everything
that I've done.
I'm not content because I know where I
came from and I don't ever want to go
back. That doesn't mean I don't
want to go back to the city.
That doesn't mean I'm going to go back
to the people that made that don't want
to go back to living like I once was.
I'm going to go back and I wanna
help. I wanna inspire them, motivate.
I want to show people that there is a
way out, that there is a way to do more,
to get more,
to obtain more.
But I personally don't want to lose
all that I've been able to get.
So I need to make sure that
I do everything to keep
it so I can't be content.
Mm.
So there is an understanding,
but I refuse to click on the switch of,
Huh.
So even if you like,
even if you have more money than you'll
ever spend for the rest of your life,
that's not what it's about.
No.
It's about the inspiring people and the
influence and constantly giving back and
moving forward in a positive way. And the
only way you can do that as a stay act,
it's the story man.